Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
I present
to you Swoveralls.
‐Oh! [ Laughs ]
‐My God.
Narrator:
...by working smart...
The ultimate sleep solution
that stops mouth‐breathing
in its tracks.
Narrator:
...by thinking big.
SPARE's a virtual ATM network
using your mobile phone.
Narrator: We're celebrating
a decade of dreams...
Christine: Our dad was
a boat refugee.
He instilled a strong work ethic
in each of us.
...and the dream
continues now.
We need your money.
‐What are your sales?
‐A dollar.
‐Oh...
‐Wow.
I must have a third
of your business.
That's not a good
"Shark Tank" deal.
♪♪
I'm Gwen.
And I'm Christine.
We're sisters, and our business
is Mavens Creamery.
Mavens Creamery is a
macaron‐ice‐cream manufacturer.
We sandwich two macarons
with ice cream.
And we only use all‐natural
ingredients
for 30 different
ice‐cream flavors.
We've both given up
our successful careers
to start a culinary business
with no formal training.
‐Hi, Dad. How's it going?
‐Hi, guys.
Our dad is our greatest
inspiration,
and we just want
to make him proud.
Our dad is originally
from Vietnam.
He had
to flee the country
from the communist regime
in 1975.
He escaped on a small boat
with 16 other people.
They barely had enough
food and water to survive.
He ended up in San Jose,
where he learned English,
put himself
through college,
and became
an electrical engineer.
He worked two jobs
seven days a week
to make sure that we had
everything that we needed
for a happy childhood.
This one's for
strawberry shortcake.
Right.
Gwen: Now we're at
a pivotal point,
and we need
the Sharks' investment
to fund more
purchase orders,
as well as invest
in automated equipment.
‐Ready to eat?
‐Almost.
Our dad's dream was
to become an entrepreneur
and have his own business,
but he had to put that aside
to support us.
Now it's on us
to fulfill his dream.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Gwen.
And I'm her sister,
Christine.
We're from
San Jose, California,
and we're seeking $400,000
in exchange for 10%
of our booming business,
Mavens Creamery.
Sharks, we are the only
manufacturer in the country
that produces
an all‐natural line
of macaron‐ice‐cream
sandwiches.
We take our homemade,
super‐premium ice cream,
form them into perfectly shaped
hockey pucks,
stick them between
two macarons
that we make from scratch,
by the way,
creating the perfect
ice‐cream sandwich.
[ Chuckles ]
Sharks, we don't want
to sugarcoat this.
We need your money.
Right now, we cannot keep up
with the high demand
and need your help
to scale the business.
Now, let's have
your sweet tooth be the judge.
Who's ready for
macaron ice cream?
‐Bring it.
‐Yo.
‐Bring it on.
‐Awesome.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Oh‐ho.
Cuban: Oh, thank God
I'm lactose‐intolerant.
Corcoran: It's like
a birthday party.
[ Laughter ]
All righty.
How many calories
is in each one?
‐Thank you.
‐On average, 150 calories.
‐You're welcome.
So, today, we have four flavors
for you guys to sample.
On your right will be
cookies 'n cream...
Thank you so much.
...followed by
strawberry shortcake,
followed by salted caramel.
‐Thank you.
Definitely not least, you got
chocolate‐toasted almonds.
‐It's very, very good.
‐Mmm.
Thank you very much.
This one's almost
like cotton candy.
You bite into it,
and you think you're gonna get
something heavy
in your mouth.
It's light as a feather.
Very refreshing, right?
Beyond refreshing.
It's really good.
It's really, really good.
This is delicious.
Mmm.
Wow, it's yummy.
So, ladies, the
[French accent] macaron,
[normal voice] as it's called,
correctly pronounced,
was developed in Paris...
‐Oh, my Lord.
...in one particular venue...
‐Oh, God.
O'Leary: ...where it still
exists today.
The macaron,
because it's made fresh
and has
a component of egg,
spoils
very, very quickly.
When you freeze these,
how long is the shelf life
of the macaron part?
Not the ice cream.
That can last indefinitely.
Yes.
But have you ever
taken one of these
and frozen it
for two weeks
and see what
it tastes like afterwards?
Yes.
Six months.
‐R‐‐
‐See? He's wrong.
Greiner: And that's what
I was gonna say.
[ Laughs ]
He's exactly wrong.
‐He's wrong again.
The macaron was not
just an elitist thing ‐‐
Anyway, so, how much have
you guys sold this year?
[ Laughter ]
Year to date,
we are at $1.25 million
in sales.
‐Wow.
‐By the end of the year,
we will wrap up with
$2.1 million in sales.
‐And will you make money?
‐And how about profit?
And we'll make money.
$167,000.
So, what ‐‐ what's
your wholesale price,
and what's your cost?
Our wholesale price
is $2.24,
and it costs us $1.08
to make the product.
It retails anywhere
from $3 to $4.
‐Great price.
‐Thank you.
So, you have
your own factory.
‐Yes, we do.
‐Yes.
Are you baking
your own macarons?
We make everything
in‐house ourselves,
the macaron
and the ice cream.
So, how do you
blow this up?
The macaron.
How do you increase it
by tenfold ‐‐
Kev, could you say it
normally, like "macaron"?
It's not macaroon.
It's a macaron.
‐Macaron.
‐Macaron. But get it right.
The point is, how are you
going to expand?
Because they're very delicate
to bake, as you know.
Mm‐hmm.
Is there any way
to scale it into a sheet
where you can stamp out
thousands and thousands?
Have you ever tried
doing that?
Those are called
vanilla wafers.
[ Laughter ]
We're at 200,000
or 300,000 a month.
How big
do you think you can get,
based on
your current factory,
and at what point
do you think you'd have
to open up
another factory
or use a co‐packer
to help you grow?
Well,
that's why we are here.
Um, we are almost
at capacity.
Do you have
a storefront?
‐No, we do not.
‐We do not have a storefront.
So, are you just supplying
different shops
in cooler sections,
like this?
Yes. So, our customers
are the independent retailers,
which are drink‐specialty shops,
fast‐casual restaurants,
as well as, uh,
grocery chains.
In regionals, correct?
Regional stores?
Regional stores.
Each and every single retailer
that carries our product
actually carries
our freezer.
Yep.
So we have our own
real estate with this wrap.
Cuban: Ah, so that's
your capital cost, right?
So what's it cost
for one freezer?
Uh, for one freezer, it costs,
on average, about $1,400.
‐That's not horrible.
‐It's so great, though,
because it catches
everybody's eye.
Do you have to fund it?
We partnered up
with an equipment company
to help
supply us freezers.
We pay them a royalty fee
for each unit
that is sold within.
‐Did I hear "royalty"?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐How much do you pay?
‐15 cents per unit.
So, how did you come up
with this idea?
Well, it really
all started ‐‐
I'm sorry ‐‐
with our father.
Our dad was a boat refugee
who fled Vietnam
after the Vietnam War,
and growing up,
he would tell us of
his experiences on that boat,
floating, really,
aimlessly for days
and not knowing if he would
live to see the next day.
And we understood
why he worked so hard.
He worked two jobs
seven days a week for 20 years
to provide for our family,
and he instilled a strong
work ethic in each of us.
And fast‐forward
to 2014,
I‐I reached a breaking point
in my life,
where I was tired
of my career.
I was
completely miserable.
So I set out to follow my dream
to become an entrepreneur.
And even though we didn't have
any culinary background
or experiences,
that didn't stop us.
We utilized our resources,
which was YouTube and Google.
[ Chuckles ]
And that's really
how we learned
how to make
the macaron ice cream.
John: So, what's the long‐term
vision for this?
Our goal is
to automate this product
so that we can produce more
and drive labor down.
You want to scale
wholesale, basically.
Correct.
That's correct.
Our labor cost
is really high,
and it's only
gonna get higher.
It's all handcrafted
and manually done.
So, with the automated line,
we'll be able to use
an extrusion machine
where they wire‐cut
the ice cream
and assemble it
as it goes down the line,
um, in addition
to packaging, as well.
‐Hey, guys, uh ‐‐
‐What does that cost?
It costs us
$200,000.
Congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
‐Thank you.
‐And the product is amazing,
right, just phenomenal.
‐Mmm. Delicious.
Here's the challenge,
right?
When business is growing,
it's great,
but your margins
are so slim, right,
$1.08 versus $2.20,
that the minute those sales
decline at all,
then you start to get
this cascade of problems
where, all of a sudden,
the retailer
who's giving you space
aren't making enough money
for that space,
and that's a real risk
for your business.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
But congratulations
on what you've accomplished.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you.
I love the product,
but I don't always invest
in everything I love.
This is a great business
for you,
but it's not
investable for me.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you so much.
John:
I‐I love the product,
but I don't know
if I can add any value. I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
You're gonna make $167,000 this
year, and I applaud you for it.
You're asking for
a $4 million valuation,
30 times what
you're gonna make this year.
You're growing,
but you're actually worth
only about $600,000
to maybe $800,000 today.
So I'm just trying to bring us
back to reality here
and say this is
very, very difficult.
Well, Kevin, we're gonna hit
over $2 million in sales
this year alone.
This year.
But your margins
are really small.
Your margins should be almost
twice what they are.
You haven't been able
to automate the process.
That's the problem.
And that's why we're here.
We need to automate
the process
so that we can
drive the labor down
and increase our margins.
I'm out.
♪♪
I could add a lot of value, but
I have a couple of questions,
but I would like
to make you an offer.
Whoa.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Barbara is Gwen and Christine's
last chance at getting a deal
for their gourmet
ice‐cream‐sandwich company,
Mavens Creamery.
I could add a lot of value, but
I have a couple of questions,
but I would like
to make you an offer.
Whoa.
Do you sell online?
Not at the moment,
but we ‐‐
Were you planning that?
Yes, we just revamped
our website,
uh, to launch e‐commerce
in the first quarter of 2019.
We'll be shipping it out in
Styrofoam boxes with dry ice.
Okay, and then the biggest
curiosity is,
how does your father
feel about this?
He's very proud of us.
He still
comes by the facility,
just hops in unannounced,
and he still has
his tool bag and says,
"Do you guys need me
to fix anything?"
That's great.
You know, last ‐‐ last year,
when we moved into the factory,
we ‐‐ we had
a small grand opening.
It was a huge deal for us
because it was a milestone,
working in our garage
for two years
to having our little own
baby factory.
And that's when ‐‐
that's when he broke down
and started crying.
Corcoran: Oh.
And that's the first time
I'd ever saw my dad cry
in my life before.
He's not a sentimental guy,
but he shows it by other means.
And he said, "I only wish
my parents were proud of me
the way that I'm proud
of you guys."
‐Oh, wow.
‐Aww.
And after that, you know,
we just had an affirmation
that we're gonna continue
doing what we do,
work as hard as we can
to fulfill his dream,
and ‐‐ and make him
proud of us.
Um, he ‐‐
he's our true superhero.
The happiest day of my life
was when I turned 35.
I had my first real profit
in my real‐estate firm,
and I ordered
my mother and father
a brand‐new
Cadillac convertible
and had my Uncle Richie
drive it down to Florida
with bows on and pull it
into their driveway.
That must've felt
really good.
Corcoran: [ Laughs ]
Do you know...
...I‐I‐I don't think
anything
could have equaled
the joy, uh, that,
that brought
back to my family.
I think the main thing
is that we just ‐‐
we hope that we can
give back to them
for the amount of work
that they've done for us.
Oh, you'll give back
a hundred times over.
I'm gonna give you
the $400,000.
You can use $200,000,
certainly in cash,
to upgrade your facility.
I'll give you the other $200,000
in a credit line,
and whatever other monies
you need after that,
no problem, all right?
But I must have
a third of your business.
♪♪
I'm a phenomenal marketer.
I know the grocery space
very, very well.
I know how to expand
a business rapidly,
and I have a team
of entrepreneurs
that are just like you,
and they help each other.
But I am asking for
an aggressive position
because I plan
to work on it.
33.33%.
What do you think?
Thank you for
your offer, Barbara.
Would you be willing
to go down for 20%?
♪♪
No, but I'd settle
at 25%.
♪♪
You have a deal!
Yes!
‐Let's do this!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Smart ladies.
‐Yay!
[ Laughter ]
[ Indistinct talking ]
Gwen:
Thanks, guys.
‐See ya.
‐Congrats.
‐Miss Macaron!
‐I'm gonna be fat,
is what's gonna happen.
I'm gonna be happy for it.
Fist bump!
[ Both grunt ]
Christine: I think what
Barbara saw in us
was her when she was young,
struggling,
and when
she finally made it
and she made
her father proud,
just like we are
making our father proud.
So there was already easily
a deep connection there.
Yay!
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 6,
Elyse and Nick Oleksak
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for their mini stuffed
bagel balls, Bantam Bagels.
You're done.
You have a deal.
All right.
Narrator: Let's see
how they're doing now.
♪♪
Nick:
Bantam Bagels is a dream
that I had
in the middle of the night
that has come into
an unbelievable reality.
When we pitched
on "Shark Tank,"
we had done $200,000 in sales
in 4 months.
In 4 years, we've done
$45 million in sales.
Elyse: We now have
three product lines,
and we're in
over 10,000 doors.
Starbucks continues to be
our biggest retailer,
selling
our mini stuffed bagels
in their 8,500 doors
nationwide.
When you're in as many
retail doors as we are,
it takes a huge back‐end
infrastructure
to support that business.
Ciesinski: On behalf of
the entire team here,
we are
absolutely thrilled.
Bantam Bagels has just
been acquired
for $34 million
by T. Marzetti.
I'd love to see it
in every freezer.
I'd love to see it even more
in every lunchbox.
T. Marzetti is a leader
in the specialty‐food space ‐‐
dips, dressing,
frozen dinner rolls.
It's the perfect home
for Bantam Bagels.
Your role is gonna be
to continue to lead and dream,
and our role is gonna be
to support that growth.
Greiner:
This is the kind of deal that
every entrepreneur dreams of.
They got a $34 million buyout,
plus they get to stay in,
running the business
as the innovators.
Nick and Elyse,
welcome to your new family.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every entrepreneur wants
to invent something that lasts.
It's like, somebody created
the croissant,
somebody created
the English muffin,
and Nick and Elyse have created
the Bantam Bagels,
and it's their legacy.
You guys are the best!
Nick: Five years ago,
we gave up our steady jobs
on Wall Street
to start Bantam Bagels
in our small apartment kitchen
in Brooklyn.
With this deal,
we have the opportunity
to grow Bantam Bagels
to be the household brand
we know it can be.
This is just
the beginning.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a convenient way
to get cash when you need it.
♪♪
My name is D'ontra Hughes
from Los Angeles, California.
My company is SPARE.
I'm seeking $500,000
for 3.5% of our company.
Ooh.
We've all had the experience
of searching too far
and too wide for an ATM.
There's never one
near when you need it,
and, unfortunately,
when you do find one,
well, it's not your bank's.
Here comes those insane
third‐party ATM fees.
I spent $5 just for
$20 of my own money.
Mm.
That seems a bit
ridiculous, right?
Well, fun fact ‐‐
the average ATM fee
in the United States
just last year was $4.69.
There weren't a whole lot of
options until we came along.
SPARE's a virtual ATM network
that provides cheaper,
more secure
and convenient access to cash,
all from the comfort, security,
and convenience
of your mobile phone.
Getting cash
with SPARE is easy.
Once you connect
your bank account
or digital wallet to the app,
you select the amount of cash
that you need.
The map will then populate
with all the merchants nearby
that are willing
to dispense that cash.
You're given a one‐time use code
that you then scan
for verification.
Scan the code
and get your cash.
You're on your way.
It's just that simple.
You get the cash you need
at a cheaper rate
than using a third‐party ATM.
And the best part?
You're supporting local business
with increased foot traffic
and revenue.
From tourists to video‐game
players with virtual tokens
they want to cash out
to prepaid card users
or on to the much larger
global marketplace
of the unbanked
or underbanked.
So, Sharks, who wants to invest
their spare cash in SPARE?
Greiner: So, that's ‐‐
that's interesting to me.
So, what's the rate?
If, let's say,
I need 20 bucks?
$3.
The way the split works
is we get roughly 1/3,
and we split 1/3 with that ‐‐
with the merchant.
And then, of course, there are
processors in that equation.
And who does
the other third go to?
Uh, our processors.
So anyone ‐‐
Okay, so you're using
a third‐party network.
‐Exactly, yes.
‐Okay.
How much can I take out?
Can I take $500 out?
So, as of right now, we do
max the system at $100.
‐But the thing ‐‐
‐How do you find your merchants,
and how many do you actually
have in your network?
So, over
the past couple years,
we've amassed a little
over 2,700 merchants.
Those are regular, small,
mom‐and‐pop‐shop businesses
that really value the increased
foot traffic and ‐‐
And that's over
what period of time?
That's over
the past 2 1/2 years.
Okay, so that's
your problem right now.
Well, so ‐‐ so allow me
to expand on that.
So you all ‐‐ I heard your
exclamation at the valuation.
That's just a gag reflex,
'cause,
you know, 3.5%?
Come on. Seriously?
Of course.
But your numbers may
actually make me ‐‐
make you right, so...
‐Yes, so let me get
to one important
number for you.
My vision for this company
has to become ‐‐
to be the ubiquitous
cash‐out option.
The only way for us to do that
successfully and virally
is to partner with
a hardware company.
We've done that.
A company by the name of BVPOS
has come in as
our strategic hardware partner.
Why hardware?
They have 933,000 units
that will be uploading
our software to their units.
You're saying they have
registers in the stores already.
They ‐‐ Yes, they already do.
They have ‐‐
Okay.
They have units like this one
you see here.
‐In every state? How many ‐‐
‐BVPOS is what, technically?
They are a POS‐hardware
manufacturing company,
one of the five largest
in the world.
So they provide
the register
and the print of
the receipt system
for all
the small stores.
That's correct.
Yes, that is correct.
But are they already
in that many stores
and in multiple cities?
‐Yes, absolutely.
‐Are they in every state?
‐Who aren't they in, right?
Because 933,000 seems
like a huge number...
Absolutely.
...but relative to the,
you know, retail landscape,
et cetera, that's not
a big number, right?
Correct,
and so, they're
a smaller company.
So one of the biggest
issues that we had
as we wanted
to scale this vision out
was proof of concept.
You go to a chain like 7‐Eleven,
and you're like,
"Partner with us."
They go, "Go get volume."
So that's what we did.
We proved with
our 2,700 locations,
which is incredibly small...
‐Right.
...that we could add value
to our customers.
How many transactions
are you doing a day?
So, on average, we hit
somewhere around the mark
of 2,500 to 2,700.
‐A day?
‐Right now?
‐A day, yes.
‐Wow.
‐2,500?
‐Yes.
O'Leary:
And how many locations
do you have right now?
That's a lot.
‐2,700. A little over 2,700.
‐No, it's not a big number,
'cause they only make
a buck a transaction.
Exactly.
It's not a big number.
‐Yeah, but it's a big number
for how many ‐‐
for just starting.
And what is your background
prior to this?
So, my background, um, I used
to work at J. P. Morgan,
and I had this brilliant idea
[chuckles] in 2010
that I would become
an entrepreneur.
But I've gone through
the process
of sleeping on couches,
sleeping in my car,
all to raise money
for this thing
that I think adds
mass amounts of value.
‐How much money have you raised?
‐$500,000 to date.
‐Okay. From who?
‐Um, friends and family,
and then we also had a small
convertible‐note round.
And what was ‐‐ what's the cap
on the convertible note?
The convertible‐note round
at that time was $9 million.
‐$9 million?
‐Yes.
‐Wow.
O'Leary: How did you
convince anybody
to buy into
a $9 million valuation?
I don't get that at all.
‐D'ontra's a sales guy.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐So, um, yes, I am a sales ‐‐
D'ontra, can I
ask you a question
about the difference
in cost?
So, I use you,
I pay $3.
I use any other ATM,
of which there's millions...
‐Yes.
‐...I pay $4.69,
so 1.69% more.
Am I actually gonna walk
an extra block for 1.69%?
Do I really give a...
‐You do if you ‐‐
‐No, but that's proximity.
It's not the walk. It's ‐‐
‐Well, here's the thing.
You do care if you're part
of the unbanked
or underbanked
population.
What you call
"underbanked population,"
I wasn't sure
what that meant.
Underbanked is someone who
doesn't have the same access
to financial tools
as everyone in ‐‐
as the people
in this room, frankly.
So they don't have
a Citibank card. I see.
Cuban: When I was broke and
sleeping on the couch, right,
I couldn't open up
a bank account, right?
You needed
to have 200 bucks.
You needed this,
you needed that, right?
‐I see.
‐They didn't give me one.
If you're someone who's living
paycheck to paycheck,
you're using our system
nine times per month.
That change in
what you would spend,
that difference between
the $4.69 and that $3
is a difference between
eating and not eating,
and that's how significant
our value is
to that particular
demographic.
O'Leary:
I wish you the best.
By the way,
the $14 million valuation,
I didn't even get a chance
to beat you up on that.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐It's ridiculous. I'm out.
Sure.
I think it's a needed idea.
I think it's a smart idea.
I don't think that I would be
as good a partner for you
as other people sitting
here beside me.
Of course.
And solely for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
I appreciate it.
I can't relate to this,
so I don't think
I'm going to be
the best partner for you.
I'm out.
John: I'm still struggling with
how the logistics will work,
'cause I'm just seeing
that a lot of store owners,
they don't want to carry
a lot of cash on them.
The store owner's making $1
per $100 transaction or $2?
‐A dollar per transaction.
‐A dollar.
So that means I have to risk
$1,000 of my register for $10.
Which is no different
than the ATM.
You have to keep in mind ‐‐
‐I know, but the ATM
doesn't have
a manpower there.
I just think, logistically,
it's going to be a challenge.
So I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I love the idea,
but 3.5% is not enough,
because, look,
you have the authenticity.
You need credibility,
right?
Yes.
‐That, I obviously bring, right?
‐I'm here to make a deal.
I'm here to make a deal.
Yeah, 3.5% is not gonna
get that done.
Okay.
So you've got to make it
worthwhile for me.
Um...
Mark, would you
be interested at 5%?
‐No.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Okay.
‐Because it means
I'm gonna have to keep on
putting money in
just to stay up
at 5%.
You get diluted by 5%,
you've still got
60‐some percent.
I'm gonna be the face,
in a lot of respects.
‐What are you thinking?
‐Mark, give him an offer.
I mean,
for $500,000,
I need 15%.
Ooh.
♪♪
So it's up to you.
Do you want
71% of a grape,
or do you want 64% or whatever
it is of a watermelon?
♪♪
Oh, my God. I'd jump.
Don't you have outside
investors, though?
We do.
Greiner: Doesn't matter.
They'd want Mark.
This is not worth
$14 million.
He raised at ‐‐
No, I know.
But he raised
at $9 million.
He raised at $9 million.
‐Do it.
♪♪
Would you consider 12%?
I'll do it at 12%,
plus 2% advisory.
♪♪
‐You got a deal.
‐Perfect.
‐Yay.
‐Oh, yay. What a happy ending.
Ooh!
This is exciting, man.
Appreciate it.
‐Thank you so much. Thank you.
‐Perfect partner.
‐I got you.
‐Appreciate it, D'ontra.
Congrats.
♪♪
Hughes:
I gave up more than I wanted to,
but nevertheless,
having Mark Cuban come on board,
it was worth it.
It was monumental.
It's life‐changing for us.
Life‐changing for the company.
[ Chuckles ]
Life‐changing for me.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Thanks to "Shark Tank,"
I have gotten to tell my story
to thousands of people
across the country.
And what I love most is,
afterwards,
they come up to me,
and they say,
"Oh, I've got this great idea.
I've got this great plan.
I've got this great invention,"
and I get to say to them,
"Go on, now. Get to one
of those casting calls.
Show them what you're made of."
Because if I can do it,
you can do it.
And you know what?
You might get on the show
and come away with a deal
with a...
[ Toy squeaks ]
...Shark.
Thanks, "Shark Tank."
Thanks, Barbara,
for believing in Daisy Cakes.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product that combines
two fashion trends into one.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Kyle Bergman.
I am asking for $150,000
in exchange for 15% equity
in my company.
Sharks,
we all love comfort.
Whether we're lounging at home,
traveling for work,
we're at our best
when we're comfortable.
That's why
I created my product
combining two of the most common
apparel concepts ‐‐
50% overalls,
super functional,
50% sweatpants,
unbelievably comfortable.
Sharks,
I present to you,
Swoveralls...
‐Oh!
‐Aah! [ Laughs ]
...the best of both worlds.
My God.
Made from sustainably sourced
organic cotton
right here in the USA,
Swoveralls possess
the functionality of overalls
while also providing
extreme comfort.
Adjustable straps allow you
to find the perfect fit,
and a functional inside,
zippered front pocket
allows you to safely store
your valuables.
Available in a wide variety
of colors and patterns,
we have the perfect pair
for everyone,
from the stadium
to the living room.
So, Sharks...
‐"Swoveralls."
...come help the world get
a little cozier with Swoveralls,
the comfiest thing
you never knew you needed.
I have some samples for you,
but before I pass those out,
I would just like to show you
a visual
of how fantastic you, too,
could look
in the Swoveralls.
‐[ Whistles ]
Cuban: Yeah, baby.
[ Laughter ]
‐Kevin rocking out there.
‐[ Laughing ] Mark.
So, Daymond, I have
this gray pair for you.
‐[ Laughing ] Thank you.
‐You're welcome.
Lori, this black pair
on top right there.
‐Oh, my goodness.
‐Thank you so much.
‐I got the navy for you, Mark.
‐Appreciate it.
You're welcome.
Thanks a lot.
Greiner: Well, they're very
comfy‐feeling.
O'Leary: The number‐one
question is,
can you have
a pee‐pee?
‐Yes, there's ‐‐
‐Yes, yours has the zipper.
‐There's a zipper.
‐Got it.
‐Yeah.
‐What about number two?
Women have been wearing rompers
and onesies for decades,
and, trust me ‐‐
and I can show you afterwards
how to go number two
in the Swoveralls,
if you would like.
‐Kev, do you have a loose ‐‐
do you have
a loose bladder?
'Cause you always
ask that question.
Do that for us.
Let's talk about
what these cost to make
and how much
you sell them for.
My cost is around $33
to make it here...
Not so bad.
...and I'm retailing them
for $95.
How many SKUs
do you have to carry?
For women, I have extra small
all the way to extra large,
which is roughly ‐‐
‐So five or six SKUs.
‐XS to XL.
‐E‐Exactly, yes,
but one of the big opportunities
and one of the reasons
that I'm here today is
that a lot of parents,
mom and dads, have come to me
and said, "I want a youth size.
I want a pair
for my infant."
So, how are
your sales overall?
So, I launched last September,
and in the last 12 months,
I've done a little over
$230,000 in sales.
And so I was direct‐to‐consumer
and just through Amazon.
Customers were reaching out.
"We want more colors."
And what I did is I did
a Kickstarter campaign in July,
and I raised about $75,000.
It's amazing because I'm able
to mitigate the inventory risk
by allowing people
to pick colors and sizes.
And so after
the Kickstarter part,
I was able to look at the demand
model by color and size.
O'Leary: Daymond,
you're the fashion expert.
Why wouldn't this get ripped off
immediately when it goes ‐‐
‐It will, but so what?
‐I mean, listen,
anybody can put two holes in
a blanket and call it a Snuggie,
but look how well
Snuggie did, right?
However,
inventory's an issue.
The only thing that killed
more people than the plague
is inventory, right?
[ Laughter ]
So my concern is that,
most likely,
50% to 60%
of his color requests
are gonna be black,
right, like in any line.
He's gonna then splinter it,
have all these other colors.
You know, I'm not sure
how it's gonna work.
Well, D‐Daymond,
you actually almost nailed
our color and
sizing profile.
I am definitely looking
at this as "Less is more."
I want to see the 20% of the
SKUs that do 80% of the business
and kind of mitigate
the risk from there.
I think that I've missed on
about $100,000 in lost sales
in the last 12 months
because of some opportunities
that have come up
where I didn't have
inventory available.
Part of the reason that
I didn't was because
I didn't have enough cash
to make more,
which is part of the reason
that I'm here today.
Kyle, can I tell you
what's gonna be
the huge challenge
in this business?
Um, I learned a most valuable
lesson recently
buying into
the Comfy brand.
Only had two prototypes ‐‐
nothing else.
And in nine months, they've had
$25 million in sales.
What was the appeal of
that garment that they had?
And I felt like I'd found
what the secret sauce was.
One SKU, one size to
a huge audience of people
that found
a use for it.
I think this has too many SKUs,
it's too narrow‐market,
and on top of that,
I think it's on trend
because overalls
are so popular,
but I don't think
that's going to last.
And I just don't think
it's gonna be an easy climb
to make money on this.
So, sadly, I'm out.
Okay. Thank you, Barbara.
To kind of answer some of
Barbara's concerns,
I want to take a step back
and tell you guys
what I plan to do
with the money.
And the first thing
I plan to do
is to scale production
in the existing inventory
with the SKUs
that I know are working.
The second thing
that I want to do
is to diversify
the product mix
while the brand
has momentum.
Plus‐size,
youth, and infant.
Another area where people have
been reaching out to me a ton
is the college market.
Kids at colleges ‐‐
Yeah, but these are
all splintered markets ‐‐
more SKUs, more size,
more colors, more sizes.
Cuban: Yeah, Kyle,
you're kind of answering
all the questions
the wrong way,
in my opinion, right,
because
if there was enough demand ‐‐
You talked about selling
out with the inventory
you had, right?
But if you saw
enough intrinsic demand,
you wouldn't
have to be thinking about
all these other markets.
It would be,
"I can't keep up,"
and that's not the sense
I'm getting,
and so for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐Okay.
‐But I wish you the best,
and congrats.
‐Thank you, Mark. Thank you.
O'Leary: Kyle, I actually
always concern myself ‐‐
when I look at
the apparel business,
it's always about the inventory.
Always, always.
And, you know, we've had
so many different ideas
come through here.
And every time you look at it
and the entrepreneur says,
"I want to go into infant
or child or teen,"
that's just more SKUs.
I‐I can't
get excited about it.
I don't know how I'd get
my $150,000 back.
And it's not about just
getting the $150,000 back.
I want to get
$2 million back, and...
I don't think that's
gonna happen here.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you, Kevin.
I'm gonna tell you
a‐a quick story.
Under Armour and FUBU started
the same exacted time,
but Kevin concentrated
for 10 years
on his moisture‐wicking
shirt.
I decided to do
a million different SKUs.
He's doing $4 billion
in sales annually,
and I'm doing
5% of that.
Because he concentrated
for 10 to 15 years,
and he never lost focus
on that goal
on what he was
going to do,
and he provided the best
one thing that he could.
And, unfortunately, you haven't
figured that out yet,
and that's why
I'm out.
Daymond.
‐So, Lori?
‐I would think that the answer
would be, you have one thing.
‐Yeah.
I mean, there's only
one thing I see here,
which is the Swoverall.
But I think you have
a lot of marketing to do.
For right now,
it's a little early for me.
I'm out.
‐Okay. Thank you, Lori.
‐Thank you, Kyle.
‐Good luck.
‐Good luck, Kyle.
Thanks, everyone.
♪♪
I think the Sharks
made a mistake today,
because in the last 12 months,
my business has done
about $250,000
in sweatpant overalls
in just a few sizes and colors.
So we're just taking off, and
I can't wait to see where we go.
I would've loved to have
partnered with one of them,
but they're just gonna have
to watch me from the sidelines.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
designed to make sleep
more restful.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Nicholas Michalak,
and I'm from McLean, Virginia.
My company is Somnifix,
and I'm seeking $500,000
for 10% of the business.
Quality of sleep is
a rapidly growing issue today,
but most products on the market
are, quite frankly, gimmicks.
We all know people
who don't sleep very well.
We all know
people who snore.
What most don't realize
is that these people
often have something
in common ‐‐
they're mouth‐breathers.
So, Daymond, come on up.
You're gonna play
our mouth‐breather today.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Here we go.
‐Do you snore?
‐Do I.
‐[ Laughs ]
So, go ahead. Hop on the bed.
Just relax.
Maybe get up close
to the pillows.
One of the biggest issues
facing mouth‐breathers
during sleep is snoring.
John: [ Snoring ]
So, you guessed it, Daymond.
Open your mouth.
Let's hear your best snore.
[ Snores
exaggeratedly ]
[ Laughter ]
Come on,
let's get a snore.
[ Chokes, gulps ]
‐Well...
‐[ Laughs ]
Michalak:
...I'm not sure what that is,
but mouth‐breathing
worsens sleep quality
and leads to discomforts
like dry mouth, sore throat,
and nasal congestion,
among many others.
[ Snoring stops ]
But simply closing the mouth
and breathing through the nose
can change everything.
And that's why we created...
Somnifix mouth strips ‐‐
the ultimate sleep solution
that stops mouth‐breathing
in its tracks.
Here you go, Daymond.
We're gonna try this thing on.
‐A piece of tape?
‐Close your lips.
I'm gonna help you
put this on
and then just pat it
into place.
O'Leary:
Put one on his nose, too,
and we can say goodbye to him.
Our hypoallergenic strips are
the first and only product
on the market that gently holds
the lips closed
to direct air flow
through the nose.
And that means
deep, quiet sleep.
As a safety feature, each strip
includes a small breathing vent
that allows for mouth‐breathing,
if necessary.
Daymond, thanks so much.
I'll let you get back
to your seat.
Corcoran: Can we see what
you look like, Daymond?
Greiner: Yeah, come here.
Come here.
Leave it on.
Sharks, the solution to
a good night's sleep is here.
So, who's going to join me to
change the way people breathe,
one closed mouth at a time?
‐Let's see some samples.
‐Yeah, bring some up here.
Daymond, I have another box
and sample for you.
John: Thank you.
There you go, Lori.
Thank you.
Oop.
‐Here you go, Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you.
‐Oh.
‐There you go, Barbara.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks, Nicholas.
‐Thanks, Mark.
‐Appreciate it.
What I'll do is,
I'll put it on myself
to show you
exactly how it works.
So, with each
one of these strips,
the first and
most important thing is
that you want to remove any
balms or lubricants on the lips.
You want to close your lips,
and you want to just make sure
that the vent is right
where your lips meet.
So, I'll put it on.
I'll also show you
what happens
if I block my nose.
You'll see that I can breathe
through my mouth easily.
So here we go.
♪♪
‐That's obvious.
‐Are you breathing?
Corcoran:
Can you say something?
[ Muffled ] You can talk
just a little bit.
Greiner: Not really.
His lips can't move.
And how do you remove it
without your hands?
You just
force your mouth open.
[ Normal voice ] Yes.
It's a gentle adhesive, so it'll
come off just like that.
Nick, you have 28
of these in one box.
That's correct.
What would I
pay for this?
And what does it cost you
to make it?
So, it's currently
$15.49.
Okay. And what's your cost
to make?
So, the cost of a box
is $5.60.
However, the landed cost
of goods is $8.60.
Okay, so you're making
about 50% margins.
A little under.
We're still on, basically,
launch pricing.
We've only been on the market
for nine months.
What are your sales?
My sales to date are
a little bit over $350,000.
That's not bad.
As a matter of fact,
from last month to this month,
it looks like we're gonna
grow about 40%.
John: And how much
have you put in?
To date, my family and I
have invested
$1.4 million
in the business.
‐Wow.
‐Ooh.
‐Yes.
‐$1.4 millón?
Yes. Well, this is the thing,
you have to do ‐‐
How can that be
for this?
Well, you have to do
clinical studies.
We went up
to Harvard Medical School.
We did clinical studies.
‐Good for you for doing that.
Yes.
Most companies
won't invest that
and they'll just wing it.
Greiner:
No, it's very expensive.
And that was the thing. I mean,
this is a 5K/10K exempt ‐‐
This is a class 1 device.
We didn't have to go that route.
But we wanted
to establish credibility.
We found that our product
reduces snores
by, on average, 72%,
up to 100%,
depending on the patient.
My wife doesn't let me say
anything during the day.
Now I can't say anything
at night.
[ Laughter ]
Why do I care
about snoring?
I don't hear myself snore.
‐Maybe ask your wife.
Right. But do you want
to bother your wife
while you're sleeping?
‐Mm.
And also, on top of that,
snoring is a disorder.
You don't want to snore because
it's gonna cause you to have
other health issues.
It could lead to sleep apnea.
As a matter of fact, the reason
we started the business
is because my father,
who is a practicing internist,
he was diagnosed 10 years ago
with obstructive sleep apnea.
If you're familiar with it,
you'll know that
they give you usually a CPAP.
That's what
you're first prescribed.
Sometimes you're prescribed
what's called
a mandibular advancement device
that pushes the jaw forward.
My father couldn't use
either of those,
because he was
mouth‐breathing.
When you mouth‐breathe
during sleep,
those products don't work.
‐Do you have a patent?
‐Yes.
We actually have
nine granted patents.
We also have international
protection in over 70 countries.
Oh, my gosh. So that's where
a lot of that money went to.
Exactly.
It was about $350,000,
was on IP expense alone.
‐Wow.
I have a million‐dollar
question for you.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and Lori has
an important question
about Nick's adhesive solution
for mouth‐breathing,
Somnifix.
What's your competition?
So, the most well‐known product
is obviously
the Breathe Right strip.
What is that?
It's an adhesive nasal strip.
You wear it here.
It's ‐‐ you know,
it's similar to us.
It's over‐the‐counter
consumer healthcare.
Definitely they help people
breathe through the nose.
But our strip
keeps the mouth closed.
John: So, Nick,
here's my thought on it.
I think you've put in
a lot of work,
and I do ‐‐ I see
the merit in the product.
I personally
was uncomfortable with it.
I think I'd try it for
two, three days
and just never
use it again.
I think it's a good product,
but it's just not for me,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
O'Leary:
Nick, could you justify
the $5 million valuation?
How'd you come up with that?
‐Yes. Yes.
First off is, again,
my family and I,
we've put in
just under $1.4 million.
We've absorbed
a lot of the risk
associated with
starting a company.
That gave us
nine granted patents.
That got us
a clinical‐trial partnership
with the researchers
from Harvard Medical School.
We have regulatory listing
and clearance
in four major markets ‐‐
the U. S., Europe, Canada,
and Australia.
Our month‐over‐month growth
has averaged 31%.
And even though we're only done
a little over $350,000 so far,
to finish out the year, we'll
probably add another $350,000
or $400,000 in revenues.
Nick, I think you spent about
twice as much money
as you needed to
to get
this off the ground.
That always causes
concern for me
in terms of
financial judgment.
It's just an opinion.
But most importantly,
my husband moved me
out of his bedroom
three years ago
because my snoring
was that bad.
We've reintroduced
a lot of people.
And I were to invest in this
or even use the product,
he might actually
move me back in.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm not going in this deal,
and I'm happily out.
‐Thank you, Barbara.
‐Listen, I have to jump in.
I find you very,
very responsible,
credible, believable,
but I'm not sure how the market
is going to respond,
how many people are going
to actually use it
for all the reasons
you said.
I believe it works,
but I'm not sure enough
about the product yet,
so I'm sorry ‐‐
I'm out.
Fair enough.
Thank you very much.
O'Leary: Nick,
I always ask myself
when I'm gonna part
with $500,000,
how do I add value
to this,
and how can I leverage
my existing portfolio
to accelerate sales?
And I'm looking at
this thing, you know,
across 30 different
businesses,
and it's an outlier
for me.
I can't make this
better for you,
other than
just giving you cash,
and that's not
a good "Shark Tank" deal.
That's why, um,
I can't go there.
I'm out.
Thank you very much,
Mr. Wonderful.
Nick, what's Breathe Right's
response gonna be to you
as your business grows?
We can be
complementary devices.
Many of our users
also use Breathe Right
because it helps them
breathe through their nose
more efficiently.
Is there any way they could ‐‐
I don't want to say "knock off,"
'cause of your patents,
but mimic what you're
doing with this
and come up with a device
that fits over lips?
They wouldn't be able
to create a device
that laterally
goes across the lips
and has a breathing vent.
Is it possible to do
a sports version of this?
As a matter of fact,
we're working on it.
We're working
on the adhesive properties
of a product
that will not dislodge
when it meets
any type of liquid.
This is a major point
for us.
Breathing properly
is incredible
for improving
sports performance.
‐Right. Okay.
‐So, that is the next step.
But your marketing sucks.
Are you willing to make changes
to the marketing
and make it
more proactive?
‐Of course. Yeah.
‐Okay.
I'll give you the $500,000,
but I want 20%.
And that's a non‐negotiable
number.
You've got to make the choice
if you think it's worth it.
Nick, he's cut your valuation
from $5 million
down to $2.5 million.
I'm sure
he's good at math.
‐That's right.
‐Well, I'm helping.
I'm worth it.
And you wouldn't be willing
to bring that up
to a post‐money
$3 million valuation?
I'm worth it.
♪♪
I agree.
Let's do a deal.
‐Okay.
‐Nice.
‐All right.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thanks, Nick.
It'll be well worth it
for you. I appreciate it.
I'm really excited.
‐Thank you.
‐Thanks, Nicholas.
‐Good luck, Nick.
‐Take care, bud.
Thank you very much.
Really nice meeting you.
Thanks.
Mark, how many people have
come in here with real studies?
‐None.
‐Yeah. Right?
I mean, that's the first one
I've ever seen.
Michalak: I'm humbled.
I'm grateful
to have an entrepreneur
like Mark Cuban
who sees our vision.
I was expecting him to actually
offer an even lower valuation.
He ended up offering
right at our floor.
I was happy to accept it.
And I can't wait to get
started working with him.
♪♪